alors mes chers collègues monsieur
rapporteur d'abord mes chers collègues
nous débutons véritablement aujourd'hui
les travaux de la mission conjointe de
contrôle sur la sécurisation à la chasse
par l'audition de l'auteur de la
pétition madamisation sanchez accompagné
de madame léa jaillard
cofondatrice du collectif
un jour un chasseur qui a porté la
pétition intitulée mort violence et abus
liés à la chasse plus jamais ça alors
avant de vous donner la parole à
mesdames je souhaite vous rappeler que
cette audition est retransmise en vidéo
sur le site internet du sénat et sera
disponible ensuite sur notre plateforme
de vidéo à la demande je souhaite aussi
ensuite pour la clarté de nos échanges
rappelé la procédure qui a été suivie
car c'est la première fois qu'une
mission conjointe de contrôle est créée
suite à une pétition
cela s'inscrit dans la volonté du sénat
de rénover le droit de pétition de
renforcer le lien avec les citoyennes et
de leur donner la possibilité de
participer plus largement à l'activité
de notre assemblée la précédente
pétition ayant dépassé les cent mille
signatures a abouti au vote d'une
proposition de loi pour des conjugue
alizés l'allocation adulte handicapé
vous avez dû suivre les débats mars 2021
la pétition 742 intitulé more violences
et abus liés à la chasse plus jamais ça
a donc été déposée le 10 septembre
dernier par vous même sur la plateforme
i pétition du sénat et elle a dépassé
les cent vingt mille signatures avant
même qu'elle n'ait atteint le seuil des
cent mille signatures les commissions
des affaires économiques et des lois et
je salue madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires économiques ont
décidé de créer une mission conjointe
ayant dépassé donc ce seuil des cent
mille signatures la conférence des
présidents sané saisi le 23 novembre
dernier en application du règlement du
sénat et elle a confirmé son renvoi en
commission et la création de notre
commission conjointe de contrôle en
conséquence et en application du
règlement du sénat la conférence des
présidents a également décidé de clore à
la signatures la pétition 742 mais aussi
quatre autres pétitions qui avait trait
aux questions de sécurité à la chasse et
qui avaient été déposées à la suite de
votre pétition pour la contester ou en
étendre le champ le 24 novembre les deux
commissions ont désigné les 19 membres
de la mission à la proportionnelle des
groupes politiques et mardi derniers
mardi le 30 novembre la mission a
désigné m'a désigné comme présidente et
nous avons désigné patrick chaize comme
rapporteur et nous avons arrêté notre
programme de travail
ce programme de travail est largement
définie par la pétition elle même et la
mission conjointe de contrôle traitera
de l'ensemble des points soulevés par la
pétition et je les rappelle les
conditions de délivrance et de
renouvellement du permis de chasser
notamment l'âge les épreuves où les
capacités médicales et psychologiques
les conditions de sécurité des chats
sont notamment les zones de protection
autour des habitations l'interdiction de
l'alcool l'encadrement des battues
l'émission de l'oefe b et de la
gendarmerie nationales notamment la
réglementation relative à l'acquisition
et à la détention d'armes et des
munitions de chasse les sanctions qui
peuvent résulter d'éventuelles
infractions le partage des espaces
naturels dans le temps et en fonction
des différents usages la prise en charge
des victimes elle effectuera également
un premier bilan du volet sécurité à la
chasse de la loi du 24 juillet 2019
notamment sur la formation des chasseurs
la rétention et la suspension du permis
de chasse en cas d'accident grave est
par ailleurs une étude de législation
comparée à d'ores et déjà été lancé afin
de prendre en compte les meilleures
pratiques étrangères et d'actualiser
l'étude très complète qui avait été
réalisée en
2007 mission a bien sûr aussi vocation à
entendre toutes les parties prenantes
sans a priori et nous commençons donc
très logiquement aujourd'hui avec vous
mesdames qui avait été à l'origine de
cette pétition nous nous rendrons
également sur le terrain pour mieux
examiner les conditions dans lesquelles
sont conduites les battues sont formés
les chasseurs et sont réalisés les
contrôles nous irons aussi à la
rencontre des victimes le travail est
donc important et notre mission va se
donner le temps de travailler son
rapport est attendu à l'été après les
élections pour étudier ce sujet en
dehors de l'émotion et des polémiques
l'objectif de la mission est donc de
traiter de la sécurité à la chasse dans
tous ses aspects mais il n'est pas
d'entrer dans une discussion pour ou
anti chasse la chasse est une activité
légale et populaire qui peut impliquer
usage d'armes à feu elle doit donc être
soumises à des réglementations et des
impératifs de sécurité particulier et
proportionnée dans l'intérêt même des
chasseurs mais bien évidemment aussi des
non chasseurs
enfin avec notre rapporteur patrick
chaize je voudrais affirmer notre
détermination à travailler pour que
autant qu'il est possible les accidents
de chasse puisse être évitée à l'avenir
chaque victime est une victime de trop à
cet égard cette audition intervenant
quelques jours après l'anniversaire de
la mort dramatique de votre amie morgane
quine le 2 décembre 2020 je voudrais
vous faire part de nos sincères
condoléances et de tout le respect que
nous inspire votre démarche
mesdames mais maintenant je vais vous
laisser la parole en avant de remercier
aussi tous les collègues présents bonne
participation aujourd'hui une grande
partie de la mission et je vais vous
laisser la parole pour une vingtaine de
minutes à peu près et ensuite notre
rapporteur aura sûrement des questions à
vous poser ainsi que nos collègues sur
remercier
finement
le 2 décembre 2020 en plein confinement
notre ami d'enfance et voisins morgan
keane a été abattu par un chasseur qui
l'aurait confondu avec un sanglier alors
qu'il coupait du bois dans son jardin
avec une tronçonneuse il était 16h45 la
nuit commençait à tomber et morgane
porter un casque antibruit orange fluo
le lendemain le procureur du lot affirmé
que toutes les règles de sécurité
avaient été respectées c'est que willy
schraen président de la fédération
nationale des chasseurs a répété le mois
dernier à propos du drame qui a coûté la
vie à joël viard qui était au volant de
sa voiture cette phrase nous a
interpellés on parle de morts on parle
de balle dans le cou sur une quatre
voies entre rennes et nantes
deux balles de gros calibre en plein
thorax dans son jardin et on nous parle
du respect des règles de sécurité parler
de règles de sécurité lorsqu'elles sont
meurtrières et qu'elle permette que les
conditions soient les gags également
réuni pour que de tels drames se
produisent c'est se rendre complice de
ces morts et les banaliser
voici un exemple de ce qu'on appelle
règles de sécurité aujourd'hui en france
en bordure de la n 12 dans les yvelines
un panneau de chasse en cours que sont
censés faire les automobilistes pour
être prudent
après la mort de morgane les lotois
autour de nous ne cessé de répéter ça
devait arriver il fallait s'y attendre
cette absence de surprise et les
réactions des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux nous ont sidéré aux quatre coins
de la france des voix s'élevaient chaque
jour de plus en plus nombreuses pour
dénoncer des comportements abusifs de
chasseurs très vite nous avons pris
conscience de l'importance et de
l'ampleur de ce problème qui dépasse l
échelle locale il nous était impossible
de continuer à ignorer la mise en danger
permanente des ruraux 7 jours sur 7
pendant six à dix mois de l'année nous
avons donc décidé de briser l'omerta est
de faire un état des lieux des abus liés
aux pratiques de chasse en collectant
des témoignages donc des ruraux nous
leur avons permis de s'exprimer en
reliant leurs témoignages sur les
plateformes instagram facebook et
twitter dont l'audience se comptent
aujourd'hui en plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes c'est comme cela
qu'est né le collectif un jour un
chasseur le 7 décembre dernier
ce collectif a permis la libération
massive de la parole des victimes de la
chasse nous avons donc synthétiser les
aspirations des ruraux et proposer des
réformes pour garantir la sécurité de
tous les habitants et usagers des
campagnes qui demande simplement de ne
pas risquer de se faire tirer dessus
chez eux et sur les chemins où il aime
se promener
depuis maintenant un an nous recevons
chaque jour une vingtaine de témoignages
faisant état entre autres deux
sentiments d'insécurité et de peur
d'aller se promener en raison de battu
non signalée d'attac de chiens de chasse
de tir proches dangereux un contrôle et
de mise en danger d'autrui d'injures de
menaces d'insultés conflits d'usagé
d'intrusion sur des propriétés privées
de blessures ou de mort d'animaux
domestiques de tirs dans des maisons des
chambres d'enfants des salons des
jardins des trains et des voitures en
circulation
des plaintes refusé en gendarmerie ou
classer sans suite même lorsque le
chasseur responsable du tir dangereux a
été identifiée
de blessures physiques et de tir mortel
voici maintenant l'express l'extrait
d'un tableau recensant les 52 accidents
suffisamment sérieux pour être relayée
par la presse concernant les non
chasseurs qui ont eu lieu entre le 31
juillet et le 29 novembre 2021 sur sa
période de quatre mois un accident a été
médiatisé tous les deux trente jours
parmi lesquels un mort nos chasseurs
onze blessés douze animaux domestiques
blessé ou tué 14 tirent sur des maisons
véhicules neufs non respect de la
propriété privée et menaces 5 entraves à
la circulation et mise en danger dans
l'espace public trois points importants
doivent être précisées cette liste ne
concerne que les non chasseurs il a eu
beaucoup plus de chasseurs tués et
blessés sur la même période cette
statistique n'est que la partie émergée
de l'iceberg car comme nous l'avons dit
nous recevons chaque jour une vingtaine
de témoignages qui rapporte des faits
similaires et qui ne sont pas médiatisés
enfin ce recensement qui est minimale
est bien la preuve que l'insécurité des
ruraux et des usagers des campagnes
avait elle général c est quotidienne et
que des mesures doivent être mises en
place de toute urgence
il est grand temps d'écouter les besoins
les demandes des ruraux ainsi que d'un
grand nombre d'élus locaux et de combler
un vide législatif et institutionnel au
niveau national afin d'empêcher que de
nouveaux drames se produisent alors
qu'ils auraient pu être évités c'est
pourquoi nous avons déposé cette
pétition sur le site du sénat qui
propose des mesures élaborées à partir
des témoignages reçus on les a déjà un
petit peu évoqué je vais les détails et
un tout petit peu plus donc on demande
d'abord l'interdiction de la chasse le
mercredi et le dimanche le territoire
national sans possibilité aucune
dérogation on rappelle que selon le
dernier sondage ipsos datant de
septembre 2021 82% des français sont
favorables à cette mesure et que nos
voisins européens ont pour la plupart
déjà adopté au moins un jour
hebdomadaire sans chasse au vu des
nombreux accidents de chasseurs comme de
nos chasseurs il est évident que la
formation des chasseurs ainsi que les
règles de sécurité sont insuffisantes et
doivent être revus partager les espaces
naturels avec des hommes armés dans les
conditions actuelles est inenvisageable
nous demandons une distance de sécurité
autour des maisons des routes et des
chemins au moins égale la distance
maximale de porter des armes nous
demandons que le permis sera renouvelée
chaque année avec un certificat
psychologique et médical à l'appui comme
cela est demandé pour n'importe quelle
licence sportive
il est par ailleurs inadmissible que
l'on continue à considérer de manière
aussi légères et laxiste l'acquisition
et la détention d'armes de catégorie c
les cales létale pardon jusqu'à trois
kilomètres qui sont bien plus puissantes
que celles utilisées par nos forces de
l'ordre ces armes se retrouvent
d'ailleurs très régulièrement dans des
cas d'homicides et d'été mini-site
commis hors actions de chasse et qui
aurait pu être évitée par exemple en
juin dernier une mère de famille a été
abattu par arme de chasse par son
ex-compagnon chasseurs sur un parking
public de monéteau l'assassin était
titulaire d'un permis de chasse était
était déjà connu de la justice pour
violences conjugales
combien ne fait divers similaire combien
d'homicide et de féminicide commis avec
des armes de chasse par des personnes
qui les détenaient de manière
complètement légal étant donné la
facilité d'acquisition et de détention
d'armes en france via le permis de
chasser nous demandons un réel contrôle
et suivi de ses armes sur le territoire
national
les victimes de la chasse doivent
également pouvoir s'exprimer en toute
tranquillité sans subir de représailles
et sans craindre que leur plainte soit
classée sans suite comme cela arrive
trop régulièrement
d'autre part nous demandant des
sanctions pénales systématiques en
réponse à tout incident survenu lors
d'une action de chasse la possibilité du
retrait immédiat et définitif du permis
de chasse et l'interdiction définitive
de détenir une arme ou d'acquérir une
âme des dédommagements et intérêts
conséquents et des peines
d'emprisonnement stricte et terne nous
demandons enfin une reconnaissance
officielle et publique des victimes
directes et collatéral de la chasse par
l'état ainsi que la mise en place
systématique d'un soutien psychologique
et financier roanne quine le petit rat
orphelin de nos organes de 23 ans qui
était présent lors du drame n'a à ce
jour bénéficié d'aucun soutien
psychologique ni financier
un législateur qui prend le risque de
faire cohabiter 98% de la population
avec 2 % de chasseurs dont les balles
sont incontrôlables et létal jusqu'à 3
km et qui le sait est donc responsable
des accidents qui peuvent en découler
depuis maintenant un an nous avons
réussi à montrer que ces drames
n'étaient pas des cas exceptionnels ni
des accidents mais les conséquences d'un
défaut de la loi qui autorise
l'utilisation d'armes dans l'espace
public alors que leur portée et leur
trajectoire mais peuvent être contrôlés
par les chasseurs
en créant le collectif un jour un
chasseur n'imaginons pas être ici
aujourd'hui devant vous un an tout juste
après la mort de morgane nous
n'imaginions pas l'importance du besoin
de la population rurale de faire
entendre sa voix lorsque son opinion et
sa souffrance sont généralement
complètement et volontairement ignorée
lorsque l'on parle de ruralité
mais les événements dramatiques récents
exceptionnellement médiatisés ces
dernières semaines se répète
malheureusement chaque année dans
l'indifférence et ne sont qu'une infime
partie de ce que subissent
quotidiennement les habitants et usagers
de la nature en période de chasse s'il
était jusque là passée sous silence par
la presse nationale et par les
institutions nous sommes efforcés depuis
maintenant un an de porter la parole des
ruraux pour rendre visibles ces
violences dramé abus ayant démontré les
anges les enjeux sociaux comme politique
ces besoins n'a jamais jusque là étaient
pris en compte ni par les eaux orité ni
par les institutions ni par le
gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous sommes fiers de porter
cette parole même s'il faut bien
l'admettre il est triste que l'on doive
jouer ce rôle qui devrait être celui de
l'état mais nous continuerons de le
tenir aussi longtemps qu'en france les
automobilistes seront tués d'une balle
dans la tête au volant de leur voiture
tant que des promeneurs des cyclistes et
des gens dans leur jardin auront le
thorax perforé tant que débat
traverseront des maisons atterriront
dans les chambres d'enfants tant que des
animaux de compagnie seront retrouvé
criblé de plombs tant que des violations
de propriété privée seront perpétré tant
que des gens seront menacés insultés ou
humiliés par des hommes armés tant que
nous renoncerons à aller nous promener
par peur d'être confondus avec des
sangliers
et pour finir on a une vidéo un extrait
de témoignages à vous montrer
je pense que vous pourrez peut-être nous
faire passer le petit film par par mail
je ferai suivre on vous le fera suivre
intéressant merci merci mesdames pour
votre témoignage
et je vais laisser la parole aux
rapporteurs
merci beaucoup et la présidente mes
chers collègues mesdames tout d'abord je
voudrais donc vous dire que nous avons
entendu l'émotion qu'elle à votre compte
tenu des circonstances
des accidents et de la proximité que
vous aviez avec une des victimes
si donc nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
et nombreux dans cette mission c'est
bien parce que nous prenons en compte
évidemment votre pétition et que nous
souhaitons apporter des réponses
ces réponses elles seront le fruit de
travail de réflexion d'audition de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
évidemment des chasseurs des non
chasseurs des utilisateurs d' espaces
comme ça a été dit et que les travaux de
notre mission feront l'objet évidemment
d'un regard attentif à tous les points
que vous avez évoquées notamment donc la
question de l'armement la question
évidemment de la prise en charge des
victimes et de l'ensemble de la chaîne
alors pour ma part il me revient de de
poser un certain nombre de questions
peut-être un peu plus précise pour faire
en sorte que vous puissiez apporter vous
votre regard vos idées aussi qui nous
permettront de pouvoir avancer dans
notre réflexion de façon objective et je
dis de façon très détaché
le plus possible à la fois de la partie
et émotion mais aussi de la partie
qui est lié à cette pratique
de la chasse et qui est une passion pour
pour certains
alors ma première question elle concerne
en fait un constat que je souhaiterais
donc partager avec vous et j'aimerais
que vous apportiez ont encore une fois
votre vos commentaires en fait si on
regarde les chiffres de façon brutale le
nombre d'accidents de chasse et est en
forte baisse depuis 20 ans
lors de la moitié
en général plus importante encore
presque une division par 4 pour les
accidents mortels
néanmoins il semble qu'une fois sans que
notre mission dispose de chiffres précis
à ce stade que le nombre d'incidents
c'est à dire l'impact de projectile sur
les habitations des véhicules sans
causer de blessures graves les avait été
évoquée serait donc lui en hausse est ce
que votre collectif a pu rassembler donc
ces données et quels sont ils
alors moi je voudrais rebondir un peu de
ce que vous dites parce que c'est des
chiffres effectivement qui sont donnés
par loire
dont
les chiffres que vous évoquez donc sont
des chiffres qui sont donnés par par le
fbi il ya un graphique donc très bien
fait avec le chef de 99 et le chiffre à
2020 et nous en fait on est un peu
énervé affaires agacé de voir que ce
graphique revient régulièrement parce
que en fait en train un chiffre de 90 9
qui est le chiffre le plus élevé
d'accidents de chasse des 20 dernières
années il ya eu 39 morts en 99 on prend
celui de 2020 où il y en a eu le moins
on était un confinement à nice tête et
il n'y a aucune
aucun calcul en fait aucune prise en
compte des chiffres intermédiaires
s'appelle otto d'évolution en fait le
calcul on l'a fait enfin je peux vous la
voyez si vous voulez c'est très simple
et on prend un chiffre un autre on ne
prend pas en compte la moyenne du nombre
de de décès ou d'incident sur les autres
années ni non plus le nombre des
chasseurs en fait qui a fortement
diminué en 20 ans donc pour nous se
calcule déjà il est tronquée donc ça
c'est une première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que les incidents qui sont
recensés sont que les incidents en fait
qui ont fait l'objet d'une enquête de la
bernerie et nous ce qu'on montre en fait
est ce que est ce qu on veut montrer ce
qu'on pense qu'on arrive à montrer c'est
qu'en fait c'est une partie infime du
nombre d'incidents total donc ce chiffre
il n'est pas du tout représentatif
pour nous en fait du malade de la
réalité d'accord mais ma question était
de savoir est-ce que vous disposer
d'éléments dont vous me dites oui vous
vous disposez des complémentaires donc
que vous pouvez
ça c'est 20 jours depuis un an il ya eu
un peu un trou cet été mais donc on n'a
pas compté boutabout parce que voilà
mais c'est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui sur
les plateformes mail twitter des
témoignages mais pas forcément des
collectes de chiffres avec ça c'est
quelque chose qui doit être fait parce
que nous on a ces témoignages donc on a
des gens qui nous envoie tous les voilà
toutes ces choses là nous l état où on
est deux collectifs non on ne peut pas
donner un état chiffré ces affaires est
en fait en tout cas ce qu'on peut vous
dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui ces
témoignages ces vingt par jour
je me permets de poursuivre les
questions j'y serai bien sûr la parole à
mes collègues donc qu'ils en auront j'en
suis convaincu vous avez évoqué des
exemples étrangers à savoir ce qui se
passait à l'étranger sur le sujet est-ce
que vous disposez des exemples à suivre
ou d'idées qui voudrait donc je demande
interpellé je vous avez des contacts
avec certains pays nous indiquer les
pays les plus pertinents en la matière
et nous dira si effectivement vous avez
fait des comparaisons par rapport au
nombre d'accidents dans ces pays
alors non on n'a pas on n'a pas fait de
comparaison non c et en fait ces
chiffres viennent d'une note du sénat je
note du sénat wii dont je n'ai pas le
bienvenu nangate in europe sur les
dj par les rentes est exactement quel
pays a fait un calvaire jours dans quel
pays
on travaille on l'a fait hormis seconde
a présenté dans la pétition donc on a
est brouillé les voilà les pays dans la
pétition qu on a évoqué c'est ce dont on
a enfin voilà dont on sait enfin basé
sur les données et les notes qui avait
été faite par le sauna il ya quelques
années donc voilà on se basait sur ça
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de contacts à
l'étranger mais voilà on sait enfin ce
que je sais c'est que au royaume uni par
exemple ça n'existe pas il n'y a pas
autant de morts en tout cas il n'y a pas
autant de morts en pologne etc si les
deux seules choses
j'avais donc à une corrélation entre
justement le fait qu'ils aient donc
moins deux morts au royaume uni par
exemple et des pratiques ou des règles
qui seraient différentes des règles
existent en france
donc vous n'avez pas ces éléments
merci
vous avez évoqué les conditions
d'obtention de validation du permis de
chasse donc en la matière quelles sont
vos propositions
pour pouvoir modifier et justement
garantir
plus de sécurité
est-ce que vous avez des propositions
oui
par exemple l'âge aujourd'hui le père
michel se passe à 16 ans à partir de 15
ans on peut aller chasser en étant
accompagnés donc en fait on peut chasser
avant d'avoir son permis de voiture
avant d'aller voter et c'est donc pour
nous là j'étais un des premiers éléments
du permis après en terme de des preuves
donc là les as tu peux dire mais en fait
il ya une épreuve pratique et théorique
et il n'y a pas de c'est à dire qu'il
faut une moyenne des deux sur les
épreuves il faut pas voilà si on gratte
l'une des deux c'est pas grave si la
moyenne correspond peut quand même avoir
le permis donc nous on aimerait par
exemple que
si l'épreuve pratique est ratée en fait
ça empêche d'avoir le permis de chasser
par exemple est-ce que donc par rapport
à l'âge je ne peux même comme un
complément est-ce que vous avez donc pu
vérifier que il ya plus d'accidents
justement chez des jeunes chasseurs que
je sais des chasseurs plus expérimentés
est-ce que vous avez des notions ça ce
sont des données est d'ailleurs à ce
point là j'ai enfin c'est là vous avez
parlé des données de la fbc quelque
chose d'aussi qu'on aimerait voir c'est
une transparence de ces données c'est à
dire que effectivement on quand on
regarde ces données on ne sait pas ce
qu'il ya derrière la définition
d'incidents et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est important à savoir en fait quand
on faut il faut vraiment définir les
termes et est donc pour cette question
de donner aussi c'est ça il faudrait des
chiffres pour pouvoir affirmer ça parce
que effectivement nous c'est ce qu'on
entend ça que ça soit voilà les règles
de sécurité ont changé ce sont les
chasseurs voilà qui ont le permis depuis
longtemps qui commettent des
voiles à des tirs mortels des choses
comme ça bon morgan qin il a été tué par
un chasseur de 32 ans qui venait d'avoir
son permis six mois avant
la question de l'interdiction de la
chasse les mercredis et dimanches en
quoi cela garantirait justement la
sécurité
c'est vrai qu'on peut aller se promener
tranquillement le dimanche ça veut dire
qu'on interdit tous les autres jours
aussi
présents plaintes de personnes ne vont
pas se promener en période de chasse et
s'interdisent d'aller sortir quand on
voit la quantité risque de se prendre
donc vous vous êtes plutôt sur une
notion de partage de l'espace peut pas
forcément sur un jour donné ou sur un
jour donné mais qui est pas forcément le
mercredi et le dimanche ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que le mercredi à
dimanche ne sont pas forcément les
éléments déterminants dans votre
proposition
pardon
au minimum le dimanche passé ces deux là
c'est quand ta demande logique en fait
on est environ 15 millions selon les
chiffres sa variante selon les la valeur
de nos calculs mais au minimum en
qualité 15 millions de ruraux il ya
environ un million de chasseurs donc
voilà c'est 15 millions à 28 millions
selon les données de l'insee de la datar
sur la définition les périmètres que
l'on prend pour désigner les ruraux où
les campagnes les zonages la veille par
des parades est la soustraction en fait
ça fait au moins de 14 millions d'euros
non chasseurs qui peuvent pas aller se
promener la moitié de l'année en fait ça
c'est pas c'est anormal je voudrais je
gagnais pas 14 millions de gens qui vont
se promener tous les dimanches mais mais
c'est facile mais en fait il a fait état
de heurts ccva le sujet ce que je
voulais dire par là c'est que quelque
part je change en tant qu' l'importance
et le partage en fait de l'espace avec
la sécurisation qui est donné aux uns et
aux autres en fonction de leur
utilisation et leur pratique
vous avez parlé aussi d'un point qui est
donc la création d'une distance de
sécurité autour des habitations
donc aujourd'hui donc cette notion
n'existe pas
selon vous quelle serait la bonne
distance
j'ai tient pas bien ce micro en fonction
des armes
on va avoir des déportés qui sont très
différentes donc est-ce que donc ce
serait donc que quelque chose
d'arbitraire ou est-ce que donc
justement il faudrait peut-être intégrer
la notion du type d'armes utilisé pour
justement définir c'est cette distance
aujourd'hui on a des armes qui tire qui
sont les tailles jusqu'à trois
kilomètres qui traverse entièrement des
maisons des baies vitrées des murs donc
en fait
si ces armes sont utilisées faut être
sûr que enfin à trois kilomètres en fait
elle ne peut rien touché on a des fins
il ya eu là c'était en novembre dernier
une maison de retraite qui a été enfin
en mayenne à mayenne qui a reçu une
balle qui avait été tiré à 1,2 km donc
effectivement en fait le fait d'avoir
des armes de telle portée devrait
obliger en fait d'être sûr qu'il ya un
périmètre de sécurité où cette balade si
elle n'attirait n'y a pas d'obstacle il
faut qu'elle ne touche en fait ni
personne ni ni aucun voilà le bâtiment
ou quoi que ce soit ou alors on réduit
la portée des a enfin oui mais ccc quand
même c'est quand même assez étonnant
qu'une arme peut aller jusqu'à dufferin
pital jusqu'à deux kilomètres qu'on
utilise dans la nature dans l'espace
public des armes qui ont une portée de 2
km ou trois mais deux
c'est pas aussi a priori on va pas tirer
sangliers cas de kilomètres de nous donc
déjà juste le fait qu'on puisse utiliser
ses armes dans la nature c'est
complètement absurde après voilà à
partir de là on peut les utiliser taxi
lent il faudrait adapter les distances
de sécurité à la portée des armes
d'accord je pense qu'il est dûment faut
avoir un regard pragmatique sur le site
sur le sujet c'est pas effectivement une
question de distance mais plus
d'intérêt par rapport à l'armée elle
même alors dans votre pétition vous vous
déploré l'absence d'exhaustivité du
fichier national des personnes
interdites
d'acquisition et de détention d'armes
sur ce point le projet de loi relatif à
la responsabilité pénale à la sécurité
intérieure qui devrait être entré en
vigueur au 1er janvier 2022 apporte des
modifications de nature à garantir à ce
fichier une plus grande effectivité pas
réellement vous vous demandez à un
contrôle et un suivi plus strict des
armes de chasse quelles sont vos
propositions en la matière
sur le contrôle
ben en fait non c'est pas qu'est ce
qu'un l'alsace qu'il faut mettre en
place du coup pour le suivi
non on sait ce dont on s'est rendu
compte c'est que c'est très affligée
sait pas où la connexion se fait pas en
fait mais par exemple dans les cas qu'on
consiste dans la pétition des gens qui
ont été condamnés pour violences
conjugales ou qui ont eu voilà c'est le
cas par exemple du d'un père qui a tué
sa fille récemment avec son fusil de
chasse qui avait enfin cette fille avait
déjà porté plainte contre lui devant toi
il y avait eu une dénonciation de
violence et enfin commence alors là
encore des armes chez eux en fait il ya
un problème le nom sait pas où est le
problème qui n'a pas retiré larmes
est-ce que c'est voilà que la plaine qui
n'a pas été au bon endroit si le
gendarme la partageons ne sais pas mais
en tout cas toujours actif évidemment il
ya un souci quelque part donc après
voilà
on vous fait entrer
en la matière donc vous avez des
exemples de ce type l'ag qu'ils
pourraient donc vous être utile sur
votre plateforme
témoignages ou des idées oui
régulièrement d'ailleurs on a un au
témoignage vidéo effectivement d'un cas
qui s'était passé dans le lot où une
femme avait donc porté plainte pour
violences conjugales par son mari
chasseurs il y avait une restriction de
périmètre elle est morte et oui oui
césar n'avait pas été retiré la question
se pose qui doit retirer les armes en
fait est ce que c'est la gendarmerie est
ce que c'est les fédérations de chasse
est ce que c'est la préfecture on ne
sait pas mais en tout cas on a plusieurs
témoignages qui font état de ce genre de
là on parle de féminicide mais aussi d'
homicides dont vous considérez que sur
ce point là donc il ya quelque chose qui
ne fonctionne pas alors même que donc
finalement de tous les éléments pour
pouvoir le mettre en place oui quand les
armes sont détenus légalement on devrait
pouvoir connaître les comportements à
risque et les identifier sachant qu'il y
a pas de contrôle aujourd'hui
psychiatriques psychologiques pour
passer le permis de chasse et obtenir là
on me dit qu'effectivement ça aussi
c'est quelque chose d'important à
prendre en compte en l'occurrence manque
effectivement je vous disais qu'il y
avait une modification donc législatives
il faudra évidemment
challenge est donc vérifier pour
corriger cet effet donc que vous évoquez
je suis désolé pourtant jeu j'essaye
d'être
ouais c'est vrai
alors question concernant les sanctions
pénales
vous dénoncez donc les rechutes plainte
donc donc certaines situations où le
classement sans suite de ces plaintes
est-ce que là aussi vous avez des
exemples précis
concernant cesser ses dires
et en plus en plus il s'arrête le micro
je suis désolé je ne sais pas quand
on me boycott
en la matière mais la question est ce
que vous pensez que il serait nécessaire
de sensibiliser
les forces de l'ordre sur ce sujet oui
complètement alors après on s'est posé
la question aussi d'avoir des référents
qui soit neutre et du coup qu'il fasse
pas partie du village en fête parce que
souvent c'est le problème c'est le
problème de la campagne est déjà en fait
qui témoigne c'est que tout le monde se
connaît tout le monde a un ami un
beau-frère voilà quelqu'un dans son
entourage qui chassent et il ya il ya un
vrai problème à s'exprimer et c'est une
réalité et il ya beaucoup de gens qui
nous font pas de représailles voilà qui
sont qui sont qui leur sont arrivés
après avoir essayé de porter plainte
après avoir dénoncé un comportement il
ya souvent une proximité on a eu un
témoignage par exemple d'un cas où le
où un jeune homme en fait avait eu une
altercation avec des chasseurs et la
gendarmerie avait donné le numéro de
portable de ce personnes à partir sa
plaque d'immatriculation
voilà enfin c'est des choses graves
c'est très grave et en fait y'a on
retrouve très régulièrement ça dans les
dents les témoignages des liens entre
gendarmerie et chassa entre le maire et
les chasseurs est un vrai problème à ce
sujet là donc peut être avoir des
référés en fait qu'ils se soient pas
qu'ils pensent pas forcément partie du
village et qu'ils soient les référents
quoi y'a quelqu'un à qui on puisse
adresser en fait si on a un problème est
qu'ils puissent à la gendarmerie par
exemple atteint je vois donc
centraliser la préfecture aucun cas je
n'ai pas de lien avec le village en tête
après ça c'est une idée comme ça sachant
que les gendarmes qui est qui et qui use
de ses dérives façon dans une situation
qui est quand même assez fort et plus
était vraiment posé
le refus de plainte ça c'est très très
quoi
il est plein de sang suite là vous nous
demandiez si on avait des exemples oui
on en a on en a 1 notamment c'était à
montpellier une belle cave dans l'est
dans le périurbain de montpellier une
balle qui a été retrouvé dans une
chambre d'enfant au bout de trois ans la
famille était sans nouvelles on a les
photos les articles avait lui-même un
reportage france 3 la plainte avait été
classée sans suite alors que le chasseur
avait été retrouvé je suis ta la balle
identifier et donc voilà ça c'est un
exemple qu'on a et on en a plusieurs en
sont
d'accord et donc on viendra peut-être
sur les toutes les informations dont
vous disposez et qui pourrait de nouveau
être utile et que vous pourriez louvre
nous transmettre de façon peut-être
justement
classés en fonction des deux c'est
différent quand vous avez évoqué aussi
donc un point important
qui est la prise en charge des victimes
ou des proches de victimes vous avez
cité l'exemple donc de votre amie
en la matière quelles seraient vos
demandes
concrètement donc on a dit un soutien
psychologique et financier non a été
choquée en fait de devoir considérer
enfin la mort de montréal en fait
c'était au même c'est la même chose en
fait ce que s'il avait était mort d'une
autre manière c'est c'est quelque chose
qui est super violent on se fait tirer
dessus dans son jardin star par la main
ses seins c'est une mort qu'on devrait
pas pouvoir accepter ni même envisagée
en fait dans notre société et le fait
que en personne soit allé lui demander
s'il advient de quoi que ce soit ça pose
question quand même donc un soutien
psychologique et financier dans quelle
mesure je sais pas mais en tout cas il
faut il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose après après ce genre de choses il
ya beaucoup de gens ici qui nous ont
écrit qu'ils nous ont dit ben voila moi
je continue à habiter dans le même
village que le chasseur qui a tué mon
mari ou le jaseur qui a tué mon père qui
a repris ses activités professionnelles
normalement et a recommencé à chasser
cinq ans ou dix ans après parce que là
en général ces dix ans maximum
interdiction de suspension du permis de
chasse et a promis si louis imprévisible
donc il ya un problème quand même
là en fait le problème est dans la
considération de ces drames qu'ont les
accidents est ce que pendant le
confinement par exemple c'est il ya une
dérogation pour la chasse c'est la seule
activité donc si l'état estime qu'il a
une mission d'intérêt public en fait il
est responsable de ce qui arrive pendant
cette mission d'intérêt public et donc
il ya une responsabilité à prendre par
les victimes en fait qu'ils sont qui
résulte en fait de cette mission
en l'occurrence sur le cas que vous
évoquez il ya une procédure en cours
oui elle est en cours donc globalement
cette procédure devrait donner lieu
justement a donc ça va
ces banques sanctions et de compin
attendant il fait qu'on n'en parle de
victimes qu'à 6 à des proches
dans la période justement de cette cette
procédure c'est ça
j'imagine mais en attendant voilà il est
tout ça les personnes lui a demandé
quelle poilade
oui je disais que enfin on parle de on
parle d'un fait qui traversent des corps
et des victimes qui sont présentent
souvent des proches la famille des amis
on parle de ça effectivement le procès
il a lieu en 2022 on ne sait pas ce qui
aura combien de temps ça va durer
combien ça va être mis en place mais en
fait c'est maintenant qu'il faut prendre
en charge c'est le jour même il faut
qu'on en charge
notamment approuvé le psychologique que
je vous l'accordé je l'entends
mes chers collègues est ce que quelqu'un
des questions complémentaires oui 2010
que
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
rapporteur mesdames en tout cas vraiment
voilà on est touché par par votre
témoignage par bien évidemment cette
initiative est en partie dont on partage
effectivement l'émotion qui est qui est
la vôtre moi je voudrais savoir sur les
accidents de chasse récents en tout cas
les plus récents est ce que vous avez pu
analyser quelles ont été les causes de
ces accidents est-ce que c'est plutôt de
mauvaise manipulation à ce que ce sont
plutôt des imprudences de la part des
chasseurs alors chacune d'entre vous a
dit qu' il y avait quelqu'un qui la
personne qui avait tué avait son permis
de chasse depuis très peu de temps est
ce que vous avez pu faire une analyse
vous remontez dans autant faire se peut
les causes et est ce que ces causes
elles sont très diverses ou est-ce
qu'elle elle se concentre autour de
certains de certains actes enfin en tout
cas donc ça c'est ma première question
est donc est ce que là aussi sur les
causes est-ce que ça se passe plutôt
quand il ya de grandes battues est-ce
que c'est plutôt lorsque la chasse est
individuelle est ce que quand il yal de
trois personnes enfin voilà est-ce que
vous avez des éléments
qui permettent autant que faire ce peu
d'avoir un peu plus de deux
éléments concernant ces différents
accidents de chasse et puis une autre
question vous dans votre pétition vous
dites il faudrait interdire l'achat
certains jours les mercredis et les
dimanches est ce que pour vous ça
pourrait être entendent abl que de dire
que plutôt que d'interdire la chasse
certains jours est ce que par exemple
d'isoler de sécuriser certaines zones en
sanctuarisant des endroits qui sont
interdits à la chasse parce que ce sont
des endroits identifiés comme étant des
circuits de randonnées ou de grande
randonnée parmi les plus fréquentés est
ce que ça vous paraît aussi une une
possibilité une éventualité qui pourrait
améliorer les choses et voir pour même
sur des lieux où il y a des par exemple
des battus on sait qu'il ya souvent
aujourd'hui parce que les sangliers je
ne prends que cet exemple la prospère
débattu importante de sanglier et y
compris aux frontières des villes pas
uniquement dans les zones les plus
rurales et les pelures trancher est-ce
que mieux indiquée mieux sécuriser ces
zones boisées dans lesquelles les
battues ont lieu afin que les
randonneurs tombe bien même il décide où
il gérait dans ces lieux soient quand
même autant que faire se peut les mieux
informés possible pour prendre le moins
de risques possibles est-ce que là
dessus vous avez des éléments à nous
apporter merci
alors pour la première question
concernant les causes est ce que c'est
lié à une imprudence et c'est alors pour
les cas mortels en fait c'est quelque
chose qu'on aimerait savoir sur la
transparence des données qui sont donnés
par le fbi parce que nous on peut enfin
regarder des choses on va à lire des
choses dans la presse en fait mais pour
donner des chiffres et des analyses ça
c'est un travail qui doit être fait avec
ces données sous les yeux il y a quelque
chose quand même qu'il faut préciser
c'est que quand on a un président
représentant des chasseurs nationale
willy schraen qui dit que même si les
règles de sécurité étaient respectées
li a en fait c'est un accident donc la
possibilité que même si ces règles
étaient respectées et que le chasseur
n'avait pas été imprudent ces réactions
c'est enfin voilà il ya un drame qui se
produit ça montre bien qu'en fait ces
règles elles sont inopérantes
voilà sur le premier point le second
point ce qu'on voit en fait dans le cas
d'un site de drame donc de tir mortel
souvent effectivement ça se passe lors
de battues parce que les armes en fait
elles sont extrêmement puissante et elle
sont mortelles après il ya beaucoup
d'incidents qui se passe donc avec des
ricochets aidé de la présente un des
explosions de plomb etc et
enfin ça n'empêche pas que si la
personne ne meurt pas en fait elle est
quand même blessé
voilà
concernant l'interdiction de la chasse
par rapport à certaines zones pour nous
enfin c'est quelque chose qui serait
absolument insuffisant il n'y a pas de
mur dans les forêts aujourd'hui si on a
des armes qu'ils cherchent qu'à 3 km
ça paraît enfin voilà y'a pas de murs
dans les forêts pour arrêter ces belles
là est le problème en fait tu restes
toujours que la portée des armes est
trop dangereuse et aujourd'hui on voit
bien quand on se promène sur des
sentiers de randonnée on peut se situer
voilà l étudiant un rebelle 2015 samuel
rinaudo il était sur un sentier de
randonnée de grande randonnée en isère
quand on voit viarhôna il ya une
cycliste qui s'est pris du plomb dans la
cheville et en faisant du vélo moi j'ai
aussi une autre question pour une balle
qui touche quelqu'un dans sa voiture à
la tête qui meurt et c'est qu'ils
traversent une voiture et qui tue sept
personnes combien de balle traverse nos
routes et nous et nos chemins et qui ne
touchent aucun obstacle ça c'est ma
question que je pose
je crois que
paul haggis allemand avait une question
puis marie mercier
merci
merci à vous pour ces témoignages on a
beau être au courant des drames liés à
la chasse c'était poignant touchant
merci pour cela merci pour travail aussi
de compilation parce que effectivement
il ya plein de choses qui que l'on ne
connaît pas parce que l'on ne trouve que
ce que l'on cherche et on voit que par
votre cité par votre association vous
avez déjà eu un écho de nombreux
témoignages que l'on n'aurait pas eu
autrement donc c'est pour dire que j'ai
parlé de la partie immergée de l'iceberg
je pense que on est complètement là
je poserai une question concernant le
dimanche et le mercredi sans chasse
je sais que vous n'avez pas pris ces
jours-là rouages à eau hasard c'est une
question sans doute de fréquentation
certainement est ce que pour vous c'est
un
ce suffisant c'est un minimum
voilà où est ce que vous voudriez aller
exactement est ce que vous y avez
réfléchi plus que ça
j'aimerais bien savoir si quels sont
aujourd'hui vos relations avec le monde
de la chasse avec les habitants de votre
terroir
est ce que il vient il ya une vraie
écoute est ce que vous faites l'objet
d'intimidations voilà les choses de ce
goût là
et puis autre question on sait que les
chasseurs et bien fondées battu parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a une prolifération
terrible du grand gibier et en
particulier des sangliers avec une
multiplication par dix dans de nombreux
départements du nombre de bêtes abattues
comment voyez-vous c'est cette
régulation du grand gibier est-ce que
vous avez des pistes de réflexion sur ce
sujet merci
d'accord alors pour répondre à la
première question sur les jours sans les
jours un chat ce pardon le dimanche mais
a prédit effectivement c'est un minimum
on pense que deux jours par semaine bon
c'est bien mais effectivement c'est pas
il n'y a pas de on n'a pas de
restriction là dessus si ça peut être
plus dans mieux aussi si ça peut être
effectivement pendant les vacances
scolaires et tout le week-end on va pas
être déçu mais le dimanche c'est le
dimanche et mercredi pour nous c'est
essentiel
voilà donc après où est-ce qu'on est ce
qu on veut aller nous on a cinq mesures
qui sont phare et qui on pense en tout
cas permettront vraiment de faire
changer les choses est de diminuer le
nombre d'accidents de le réduire à zéro
et donc voilà on a déjà commencé par là
par rapport à nos rapports avec avec le
monde de la chasse on a eu des contacts
on a eu des échanges avec des chasseurs
on est régulièrement insulter sur les
réseaux sociaux mais bon après c'est un
reste assez bas
c'est alors que près on s'y attendait
plus ou moins donc donc voilà
oui voilà donc c'est pas ces paroles
assez normal ou inertie et les
intimidations enfin on a eu nous on
n'habite plus dans le lot actuellement
on a eu des échos par contre de gens qui
donc d'une de la soeur de miley très
concrètement qui était qui a été voilà
qui a été interpellé par une fan de
chasseurs qui l'a dit donc dans le
village à côté de cages à gaillac qui
lui a dit vas
attention ça ça serait dommage que y est
notre accident c'était une mise en garde
sous la forme d'une menace donc ça ça
arrive et effectivement le les retours
qu'on a en tout cas de la part des
chasseurs c'est c'est que de toute façon
nos mesures elles sont stupides et et
qu'elles sont inapplicables voilà il n'y
a pas de débat possible
concernant les battues au grand gibier
on a un projet en fait par rapport à ça
c'est que si on considère qu' on est
obligé de réguler la population de
sangliers ça veut dire que c'est quelque
chose qui doit être mise en place par
l'état et contrôlée par l'état pour nous
on peut pas donner ce pouvoir là à des
gens qui sont pas formés pour ça et qui
savent pas en fait qu'ils sont pas
formés non plus ni à la biodiversité ni
au maniement correcte des armes est en
fait qui ont leurs données en fait ce
droit là on leur donne le pouvoir de
dire ben moi je suis plus j'estime que
vous les promeneurs les cyclistes les
randonneurs à être là parce que je suis
un métier de missions d'intérêt général
à partir du moment où l'état le demande
pour nous il faut que ce soit régulée
d'une autre manière en fait faut que ce
soit professionnaliser
si
d'après monsieur mérillou merci madame
la présidente sur à porter mes chers
collègues je voudrais déjà vous vous
remercier mesdames pour avoir lancé
cette pétition et on comprend la
souffrance qui pètent la vôtre et ce
besoin que vous avez surtout d'éviter
que ça se reproduise si je comprends
bien
in fine et vos propos donc bien axé sur
la prévention je voudrais faire trois
remarques la loi de juillet 2020 en fait
renforcer les dispositifs de
confiscation des armes c'était la loi
qui est arrivé après le grenelle sur les
violences conjugales et il y avait des
dispositions pour renforcer la
confiscation justement quand il y avait
des antécédents de violence conjugale
donc je pense que peut-être vous avez eu
connaissance de cela ensuite en ce qui
concerne ce qu'on peut appeler les
victimes témoins s'étaient aussi dans
cette loi ou un enfant qui voit là sa
maman subir des violences on considère
que en tant que témoin il est victime
donc je partage complètement l'idée de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
préconisations pour les témoins dans le
cas d'accident aussi violent et aussi
choquant que celui là pour qu'il ya un
accompagnement sérieux qui doit
effectivement être mis en place très
rapidement sur le plan psychologique les
accompagnement psychologique ça coûte
cher donc effectivement il faudrait
qu'il y ait des dispositions qu'ils
soient prévus pour cela ensuite je
voulais savoir si vous aviez consulter
ses santé publique france qui publie des
opuscules y en a un qui s'appelle décès
traumatique en pratique sportive puisque
la chasse est considérée comme une
pratique sportive donc les éléments que
j'ai pu consulter consultez on voyait
qu'effectivement il des sports dangereux
il ya des morts quand on fait de la
plongée quand on fait de lui et lemm
quand on fait du ski mais moi c'est de
la mort concerne l'usagé lui même et ne
concerne pas sauf de rares cas les
spectateurs en bord de piste ou un
malheureux qu'ils traversent à ce moment
là et donc la suède avait fait des
préconisations qui s'était rendu compte
que les accidents de chasse et est
beaucoup liée à l'erreur humaine mais
les préconisations qu'ils avaient qu'ils
avaient fait en fait avait amené
vraiment une grosse diminution du nombre
d'accidents est ce que vous avez eu
connaissance de cela
moi j'ai pas eu connaissance de cela et
là non plus oui non donc n'ont pas les
connaissances
merci
tim et riom oui moi je suis étonné de la
masse d'informations que vous avez pu
recueillir avec une association je
suppose qu'ils aient qui est
relativement jeune puisqu'elle a été
créée à partir voilà et donc je voulais
savoir si vous avez d'autres
associations qui me paraît légitime et
qui vous aide dans la compilation de
cette masse de documents parce que si
vous à tous les deux et peut-être
quelques amis vous avez pu recueillir
cette masse de documents je suppose que
l'office français de la biodiversité
sera en capacité de donner aussi un tas
d'éléments et moi je suis très preneur
là dessus
sur la régulation et c'est aussi une
question composera l'office la
biodiversité on régule un excès de
population et en le régulant en tuant
des animaux ce qui est la méthode
probablement la plus simple mais il ya
peut-être d'autres méthodes
biologique pour réguler des animaux que
d'en lâcher ou ou d'avoir des quantité
d'animaux qu'il faut ensuite réguler
donc
je suis pas sûr que vous soyez poser ces
questions là mais je crois qu'il faut
voir aussi qu'on les voit avec l'office
de la biodiversité qu'on la met mais sur
comment vous vous organiser ça c'est à
titre de curiosité parce que vous y
consacrez probablement énormément de
temps si j'ai bien compris oui alors on
n'est pas aidé par d'autres on n'est pas
aidé par d'autres nations et soutenue
par des assauts avec à petit on a déjà
demandé des conseils plus de stratégie
ou comme ça mais par contre pour la
compilation des informations on est on
est quatre actuellement dans le
collectif et on a on a tout fait tout
seul après on a beaucoup d'abonnés du
coup qui nous relaie voilà des qui dès
qu'ils ont échos d'un accident d'un
incident c'est voilà on est on a des
gens on va dire qu'ils nous aident par
la force des choses parce qu'ils ont
envie de de témoigner de ce qui se passe
à côté de chez eux et c'est ce qui s'est
passé mais mais non là c'est clairement
oui on y passe beaucoup de temps et on
travaille tout à côté donc je pense
élections que le fbi serait en mesure de
donner des données précises
et pour ce qui concerne la régulation
alors il ya des humains
je crois que ça l'a récemment il y a eu
un test qui a été fait vers barcelone
avec la stérilisation des sangliers donc
il ya d'autres choses qui sont faites au
niveau européen on peut regarder mais
effectivement cette question de la
stérilisation je crois qu'il ya eu un
test assez récents qui était plutôt
positif donc voilà il ya des exemples à
prendre dans nos voisins européens ça
c'est sûr c'est des choses qui sont
sûrement plus coûteuse et qui sont
compliqués à mettre en place il faut
faire super attention avec ces sujets
mais c'est pas impossible ça se fait si
on a envie de s'en donner les moyens à
prendre l'exemple aussi de genève du
canton de genève où la chasse est
interdite depuis longtemps maintenant
c'est plus lentement que l'année mais en
tout cas je pense avant les années 80 et
et en fait elle a été interdite par
rapport à la sécurité est depuis la
régulation des sangliers se fait par des
professionnels
ah voilà la nuit il ya des points on les
tue quand même mais il ya des points
d'agrainage qui sont précis qui sont
connus il ya un calcul et une prise en
compte exact du nombre d'animaux qu'il
faut qu'il faut tuer et ensuite voilà il
ya des gens m'ont aidée par l'état qui
vont et qui est et qui tuent relatant de
sangliers la nuit il ya aucun risque
pour la population humaine et je me
rendors voilà depuis un mirador repas et
on sait maintenant combien d'espèces
sans résultat combien de dernier mot on
doit être régulier et c'est donc ça
existe des solutions il y en a il faut
il faut juste les chercher et trouver
laquelle est la plus applicable et la
moins coûteuse peut être coûteuse de
manière immédiate mais je pouvoir aussi
sur le long terme
frank bonneville
merci présidente et merci pour votre
exposé moi je voudrais revenir peut-être
sur vous avez évoqué le bien évidemment
le partage la nécessité de partage
l'espace
et notamment au travers l'interdiction
souhaitable selon vous de la chasse dans
un certain nombre d' espace le mercredi
et le dimanche
et je voudrais peut-être
vous alliez plus loin sur ce oui pardon
vous là je vais retirer le masque vous
alliez plus loin sur ce sur ce sujet et
ce pauvre est ce que on peut entrevoir
peut-être une
une capacité à faire savoir à mieux
informer à mieux organiser aussi la
chasse sur les territoires pour faire en
sorte parce que il faut bien le dire ce
qui est la réalité de terrain sait que
c'est que dans une journée de chasse
dans un massif qui peut comprendre
plusieurs centaines d'hectares il n'y a
qu'une une infime partie qui est chassé
donc
il y à là peut être un sujet aussi de
meilleures informations de meilleure
déclaration
antérieure à la
dent par anticipation pour que les
riverains les usagers puissent aussi
davantage
utilisé des espaces restants et se
protéger pour éviter des espaces chasser
alors comme lundi me va tout à l'heure
déjà effectivement y'a pas de murs dans
les forêts ou dans les massifs
montagneux donc isolé la chasse à une
partie d'un massif ou d'un père naturel
etc ce serait pas suffisant dans la
mesure où les armes ont des portées de
plus de 2 km et par ailleurs c'est
encore une fois aux promeneurs de
s'adapter donc à une majorité de bureaux
à s'adapter à une minorité de gens non
qui sont armés camp nou a priori quand
je vais courir au corps je vais me
promener je risque de tuer personne donc
ok on pourrait avoir voilà c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait être complémentaires
par exemple les jours du cou ou la
chasse n'est pas interdite ça pourrait
être quelque chose
qui doit rentrer en compte aussi dans
des réseaux sécurité plus strictes et
dans des mesures à prendre en compte
mais ça sera dans tous les cas pas
suffisant alors c'est sûr qu'il ya
quelque chose à faire en termes
d'information ça c'est une évidence
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
enfin les habitants des dix villages ne
savent pas en fait quand une battue sur
quel périmètre al ces temps où est ce
qu'ils peuvent se ramener à une battue
ces mobiles aussi ça se déplace donc
c'est ça aussi à prendre en compte
et il n'y a pas de système
uniformisé homogène pour accéder à ces
données c'est très très compliqué parce
que enfin voila c'est selon toutes les
communes les départements et c'est donc
ça effectivement il ya un manque et il
faudrait qu'ils aient ça
après ça n'empêche pas de voile à de
tomber nez à nez avec un chasseur qui
voit là à l'affût ou des choses comme ça
donc il ya aussi un problème de sécurité
qui dépasse enfin voilà 7
7 cette information
d'autres questions
non pas de regret si la présidente tout
à fait
merci mademoiselle pour ces témoignages
qui sont évidemment très important et
qui ont prévalu à la création évidemment
de cette mission d'information
on n'a pas parlé ou alors j'étais
inattentive du problème de l'alcool est
ce que vous avez dans vos témoignages
beaucoup de choses qui pourraient être
liés ou alors je sais bien que vous
n'avez pas toutes les informations parce
qu'en fait vous n'avez pas les enquêtes
ou ou même c'est même pas recensé
d'après ce que vous nous dites mais
est-ce que vous avez quand même quelque
part voilà c'est tout à fait
politiquement incorrect ce que je veux
dire mais je le dis quand même voilà
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose là dessus
un point là-dessus qui est que vous avez
taupe et donc vos témoignages alors déjà
on a été choqué d'apprendre que l'alcool
à la chasse n'est pas interdit y a pas
de loi qui interdit de chasser en ayant
consommé de l'alcool et dans les
témoignages ça revient quand même assez
régulièrement des gens qui témoignent
bah voilà deux repas arrosé entre
chasseurs et des gens qui vont chasser
ensuite enfin voila c'est encore une
fois normalement quand il ya un accident
et que le taux d'alcoolémie est positif
c'est une coin circonstances aggravantes
et il doit y avoir une sanction pénale
plus
plus importante mais voilà après dans
les témoignages qu'on ressasse elle
reviendrait très souvent aussi oui voilà
rien n'empêche d'aller à la chasse en
ayant bu alors qu'on ne peut pas
conduire voilà il ya un taux minimal
et donc oui on a des exemples de voilà
c'est plutôt ça sera plutôt des
témoignages qu'on a ou il ya des
altercations entre des promeneurs et des
chasseurs ou alors sur la route des
accidents de voiture ou des choses comme
ça
oui ça serait ainsi
pas d'autres questions si une dernière
mesure seulement merci madame la
présidente c'est juste pour rebondir je
trouve ça intéressant d'avoir cette
cette notion d'alcoolémie peut-être que
je pense qu'on manque cruellement de
statistiques surtout ces problématiques
de chasse et on voit bien que sans
vouloir voir un côté péjoratif on reste
dans l'amateurisme et on est juste des
gentils collecte et on a très peu de
données
même dans l'accidentologie est ce qu'il
y en a plus l'après midi que le matin ça
serait des choses à l'inter intéressante
à savoir parce que ce qu'il faudrait pas
interdire la chasse l'après midi parce
que effectivement il ya des des effets
collatéraux donc je sais pas comment on
pourra compilé nous est ce qu'on peut
trouver d'autres informations mais après
avec l'ol
je pense que c'est des des données très
très importante pour essayer de cerner
au mieux le sujet et ce qui pourrait
limiter tout à fait je suis entièrement
d'accord et c'est sur ça que aussi que
je voulais conclure avant de vous
remercier pour cette audition et vous
dire que le sujet vous l'avez vu au vu
des questions que l'on a que l'on vous a
posé et encore on ne peut pas rester non
plus des heures à vous retenir mais
c'est un sujet très vaste et très
complexe avec des difficultés sur la
réalité des chiffres entre les chiffres
officiels et puis le chiffre noir et
vous vous avez témoigné sur le nombre
tous ces nombreux témoignages que vous
avez sur votre site on est sûr sur cette
difficulté d'appréhension du phénomène
réellement d'aidé de l'accidentologie
sur la nature aussi sur les causes et
les contextes et le contexte aussi de
ces accidents non ça je crois qu'il va
falloir qu'on ne creuse et on verra avec
les services de l'état et et on va
auditionner près de près de 40 auditions
pendant six mois donc on aura je pense
de quoi faire le tour de la question est
en tout cas n'hésitez pas si vous avez
aussi des compléments à rajouter vous
n'hésitez pas à nous en faire part par
mail yahoo on prendra en compte et merci
en tout cas pour votre témoignage
merci pour votre écoute merci à vous
[Musique]